and welcome to Sophie and calm Sophie
sherbert not say Trump's planned for US
troops to remain in Iraq has concerned
Baghdad and angered Tehran how will Iraq
balance out everyone's interests here
without forgetting its own will I asked
former iraqi prime minister haider
al-abadi as iraq gathers the rubble
after the bloody war with Isis the
country's American and Iranian allies
are locked in a confrontation with each
other each pressuring Baghdad to join
their side can the internally divided
and unstable Iraq afford to join another
fight will it be able to preserve the
hard-won internal peace or will the
quarrel between Washington and Tehran
pull the country apart
hi there former Iraqi Prime Minister
welcome to the show it's great to have
you with us on our program today
so mr. Holabird a Donald Trump has
recently said that he wants to u.s.
troops in Iraq to quote watch Iran
obviously that's caused an uproar in
Baghdad with Iraqi politicians
condemning Trump in unison but can Iraq
really do anything about it can they
dictate terms to Washington well is this
is very very unfortunate because there
is an understanding and agreement that
the existence of foreign troops
including US forces here in Iraq is to
help Iraqi government fight terrorism
it's not a job of foreign troops to spy
on our neighbors or using Iraq a
springboard against our neighbors this
is not allowed in our Constitution Iraqi
Constitution and this is not part of the
whole of this operation the number of US
troops in Iraq are limited they don't
have free movement in Iraq they have to
move with the consent of the Iraqi
government they don't have barracks for
their own they don't control the sky and
if light in Iraq or outside Iraq should
be by the agreement of America
government so I think the whole thing is
outside the scope of the relationship
between the two countries is very
unfortunate
can Araki forces maintain security on
their own if my dot shows America the
door
well Iraqis give a lot of sacrifices to
fight - the people who fought on the
ground are only Iraqis yes we receive
support we receive support from our
allies from international coalition and
from the rest of our friends in terms of
the just take in terms of training and
in terms of providing some air cover to
support our forces but in actual fact
the only forces who are fighting on the
ground are Iraqis yes we can sustain
this by out on our own but I think this
is not right
terrorism is an international phenomena
and - is an international terrorist
organization who not only have
threatened Iraq but a flood threat in
the region the whole world so it is
right for the countries to cooperate to
face this enemy and to quash them and I
think we have to work together so yes we
have to work with others in order to get
rid of this terror organization
altogether so the head of a Shia militia
group said that the Iraq has
capabilities to expel US troops if
needed are the Iraqi militias fired up
enough to actually come to blows with
the US forces in the country well
according to the Iraqi Constitution
there is no place for militias in the
country by militias I mean armed groups
who are outside the control of the state
this is against the State against the
Iraqi people and should not be allowed
within telleth and will not allow it if
there are regular men who are out acting
outside the state they will be the
enemies of Iraq they should not be
allowed inside Iraq as opposed to the
other armed groups who are within the
state we have the army we have the
police we have the public mobilization
force who have been now organized by the
law which is legislated by Parliament
which is applicable now to the public
mobilization force who are within the
framework of the Iraqi security
apparatus and they should show they are
answerable to the commander-in-chief and
to the rest of the security apparatus if
you ask me do we
rhaggy elements or elements while
outside the control of the stage to act
in Iraq no we shouldn't this is outside
Iraq against their our Constitution
against the will of the people and is
not allowed in Iraq so the cost for the
US withdrawal were also sparked by the
fact that during his surprise visits in
the December President Trump didn't
bother to meet any Iraqi officials is
this insult something that could have
long-term repercussions for us rocky
ties well again I think it is I mean
according to mr. Trump is this is his
well he wanted to visit his troops
during Christmas time this is his own
decision on the other side the Iraqi
government gave permission to mr. Trump
to visit his troops in in Al Asad Barak
in Western alum bar in my opinion this
was not organized properly I think from
day one it should be have been organized
in a way for officials Iraqi government
officials to meet the President of the
US when he comes to Iraq and the meeting
could have been done in by that but I
think it may be mismanagement which has
led to this this was unnecessary at all
it has poisoned the relationship
slightly but I hope we should move
forward and forget about it so at the
same time during the crucial stages of
the war against Isis United States air
power came to Iraq sate and the
coalition helped Iraq retake Mosul do
you think that it's a bit ungrateful
from the Iraqi politicians to be blaming
the Americans now and bragging about
Iraqi independence I mean what everyone
was so happy to receive help in its time
of crisis nobody wanted them out back
then oh well I think I mean this is a
habit of politicians in every country I
mean they look at the day-to-day running
of the country and of course they want
to attract support from their
constituents I think at a time
so that our allies they stood with us to
fight our enemy that terrorist but it
doesn't mean that you give a blank a
blank check to whoever has has helped us
yes we have to be grateful for those who
stood with us but at the same time Iraq
solvent is very important and the war is
over if there is no need for the troops
to stay in Iraq then there's no need but
if there is a need we should think you
over we should discuss it in our
Parliament with the government with our
political bloc's and we should decide
what is the best for Iraq at the end of
the day what we're going to apply is
what is the best for Iraq and we don't
have any hostility to those who helped
us to get it or - at all Turkey has
bases in northern Iraq set up during the
fight against Isis from which it fights
to kurtz
now we hear Iraqi politicians protesting
America's president is loud and clear
but they're not so vocal about the
Turkish bases where's that crime from
the Shia militias about that I mean it's
the Iraqi referee condemning Americans
just an attempt to look tough and the
entire US for voters maybe well I think
it has become like a lot of proxies you
know there is hostility between the u.s.
and Iran and is a matter of proxies here
in Iraq where every side is using their
proxies and their fight against each
other yes I agree there are few Turkish
military bases they did some some of
them they date back to the time of the
death of Saddam Hussein when he was in
power in the 80s during the iran-iraq
war and later on and of course we should
not accept any military existence of
foreign forces without the consent of
the Iraqi government I think in my
opinion I agree with you it we must be
partial on this it shouldn't be double
standard but after all we are part of
this region and the disagreement between
states especially between Iran Indian
states it has its impact on us my call
on my colleagues and the political
establishment
is we should confine our our interest in
the for the interest for the Iraqi
people sovereignty of Iraq who should
not be part of any proxy towards this or
that so back in 2017 hew announced
victory over Isis in Iraq but Isis
attacks still happen every day in the
country and the group still holds a
chunk of desert and in northwest was
your optimism shall we say a little
premature how long is it before Isis is
routed out completely if that's ever
possible yes if you go back to 2013 I
was very careful I said we crushed
- militarily we liberated all our land -
doesn't hold any territory inside Iraq
and they don't what they are holding
they are holding some territory in an
Eastern or North East in Syria which is
bordering the Iraq which is very
dangerous because if they are given a
chance they can go back to terrorism at
the moment the extreme of - the danger
of - is that they're trying to wage some
terrorist attacks and against the
civilians inside Iraq city they haven't
succeeded yet we crush them we
strengthen our intelligence at the time
there is a fear that - is concentrating
on another a campaign of thirst attacks
against civilians and I hope our
military and our security and
intelligence are up to it they were up
to it and if they should carry on with
dismantling this very dangerous
terrorist organization this is not only
against Iraqis against the whole region
against the world if they are given a
chance so we should stay focused until
we eliminate this territory Russia
organization altogether so United States
has a relationship with Iraq and
neighboring Iran has a relationship with
Iraq but United States and Iran are
rivals can Iraq maneuver between these
two centers of power and keep it its own
independent magenta intact or will it
have to choose sooner or later well I
think our choice is clear we happen to
have the longest border with our
neighbor Iran
the US doesn't happen to have a border
with with Iran I'm sure if they had they
work with what they would have so
differently how to deal with your honor
how to treat Iran when you are a
neighbor to another state you have to
look at your interest and the common
interest between the two nations we
cannot move away from our neighbor they
cannot move away from us so there is
religion such as history there's trade
there are a lot of amalgamating
interests between our two nations and
our two states we have to safeguard our
own interests
we shouldn't be party to this
disagreement and this polarization of
relationship owners to do with us to be
honest with you this is a nuclear
agreement between the five plus one
members of the world community and Iran
and the u.s. decided to walk out of it
and we why should we be a party to this
and we should be concentrating on our
and just our issue where there aren't
very important for us our relationship
with the US is very important for us we
can achieve a common interest between
the two and we should be very much
focused on this know not to allow any
party to drag us along the wrong
direction all right thank you very much
we're gonna take a short break right now
we'll be back with haider al-abadi
former prime minister of iraq discuss in
the past present and future of the
country and it's fragile relations with
the united states stay with us
[Music]
we're back with haider al-abadi former
prime minister of iraq talking about the
current situation in iraq so the
militias fought Isis with Iran's help
advisors military equipment all of that
and the Americans keep saying that this
is all Iran's influence tools in the
country is that so well I think you're
we we didn't have any I have to be still
on this we didn't have any fighting
force Iranian fighting force on Iraqi
territory all we have we dealt with
those of the countries we purchased arms
and we got advisors and trainers to our
forces we needed that because if you
remember 2014 there are also into Iraq
and which led to then gaining control
over large chirchi of Iraq some of our
army and seriously divisions has
collapsed so we have to seek support we
have to seek training and other
logistical support from other countries
and we did this this doesn't give
influence two-disc ensure that and we
hope it doesn't we have to be careful
here in Iraq we don't want to lose our
sovereignty by fighting - we did fight -
we want to get back our sovereignty and
we have to straight that this is for the
best interest of ours and for the best
interest of our neighbors and rest of
the international community we are very
focused on this now if the u.s. sees
this as an Iranian influence I disagree
with him this is none of your very Nyan
unfortunately look at the US presence in
Iraq as again this is US interest and
trying to track Iraq into the other
direction of being against Iran we
shouldn't be against Iran were no
against the u.s. we are against
interfering into our own affairs and we
are Pro Iraqi interests or mutual
interest between Iraq and the rest of
the world so the rise of Isis was
largely fueled by the grievances of the
Sunni population against the government
could the current empowerment of a
largely Shia armed
one that's difficult to control result
in more Sunni outrage well we shouldn't
revert back to sectarianism which was a
disease and really which has led to -
being able to run over large territory
foreign country I think we have
succeeded to reestablish our security
forces and armed forces as a national
force which are now trusted by our
population at large including the
population in the liberated area we are
happy with this and we should continue
along along this now any deviation from
this is very dangerous this can damage
and can threaten our own national unity
and can lead to another upheaval we I
have been very careful and during my
term as a prime minister as
commander-in-chief to make sure that the
security forces around forces are
serving the population they are
protecting the population are they
belong to the population there is no
sectarianism or ethnicity in our armed
forces they belong to the country and
our protector of the country they are
the National yours who liberated these
areas and they should stay as they are
I'd rule you if there are militias
outside the state and trying to act
outside the state this is very dangerous
because this will give rise to another
terrorist organization and we should all
United be united against it recently
United Kingdom pledged the equivalent of
40 million dollars in an assistance
package to Iraq to bolster its economy
and reduce its reliance on Iran and
that's how the UK's Middle East Minister
put it but trade between Iraq and Iran
runs into the tens of billions of
dollars can 40 million make a difference
is there a truth to that I mean how
dependent is Iraq on Iran in terms of
its economy well there's no dependence I
think there are two neighboring
countries that is an order benefit and
that benefit to have trade between the
two countries and we cannot stop this
trade the majority of this trade is by
private sector and I don't think is the
job of the government to stop the
private sector from being active this is
a benefit to our own citizens to our own
private sector
and the benefit to the again to the
population of Iran this is a mutual
interest we should encourage it ask to
the payment of course as I said in my
press conference when I was Prime
Minister we cannot deal in dollars
because the dollar is the US currency
and the US Federal is controlling that
currency so Nederland us nor the
Iranians can use that currency between
us we can use other currencies European
has probably developed some tools which
can we can utilize to avoid the
sanctions against Iran I think while
abiding by our own interests and the
interests of the rest of the States
we don't want sanctions to be applied
against Iraq because this will be very
harmful trailer we have to protect the
Iraqi interest on this but at the same
time we are no acting proxies for this
country to apply sanctions against
another country were not party to this
and we shouldn't why are Iraq irani and
economic ties such a concern for United
Kingdom and the United States why do
they care so much well I think they have
a problem with Iran Iranian Revolution
from day one and although this has
passed I think more than 40 years ago
but still there's a problem there I
think they have a problem with Iran they
want to curtail Iran they want to
contain Iran they think any relationship
with Iran is is harmful to them but of
course every country is right to look at
its own it's as they're looking at their
own interest we should look at our own
interests as well so I think countries
compete towards achieving their
interests and we should compete with
others to achieve our own interests but
when you look at it on the other hand do
you think Iraq actually benefits from
this tensions between Iran and the West
from a situation where everyone is
interested in in buying influence I mean
those subsidies will come in handy at
some point won't they well is well I'm
not sure about this I know competition
is good but conflicts are bad conflicts
will lead to the loss of your own
resources look at our country it was
rich it was developed
look what the previous
has done has involved us in tours into
regional conflicts and we lost a lot of
that all our wealth was lost in actual
fact our own wealth was you destroy our
own country we don't believe in
conflicts we conquer we believe in
competition competition is healthy and
good if it's not done according to the
right rules and to bilateral
relationship and respecting sovereignty
we don't mind competition in fact we're
welcome it
Butwell against against conflicts
conflicts causes war causes loss of of
resources and we don't want to be in
that game we're not party to this so
Iraq is still considered one of the most
corrupt countries in the world and
former Iraqi national security adviser
ofre bhaiya told me that corruption
taints all levels of government all
areas of politics right now the current
prime minister Adel Abdul mati has
reestablished his supreme
anti-corruption council what are the
guarantees that this body won't be mired
in corruption itself well I think this
is very important this council which
really was established during my term I
have the last meeting in April 2018 and
I think that Colonel Prime Minister
carried on with it with some
modifications to it which i think is
very good it's important to have some
apparatus which will oversee how we
should compact corruption corruption is
you have to combat it by making people
aware by enlightenment by education by
enacting new laws by bringing all
resources to fight corruption I think
the most dangerous corruption is
possible corruption while political
parties they take part in that
corruption they use their position in
the state to advance their own interests
against centers of the people this is
very dangerous we have to I think we
have to make sure that we cleanse our
own acts as politicians in Iraq and we
should do that at most to stop this
corruption corruption the culture if you
don't stop this culture you cannot fight
corruption you have to put the light
post
justified corruption shouldn't be used
used against political enemies this will
lead to the wrong thing in actual fact
it'll lead to more corruption I think we
should very bad partial those who are in
power they should be very partial in
fighting corruption they have to fight
the essence of corruption we have
started this procedure it did take time
till it shows as a result I hope the
current government will be successful in
fighting corruption the core of
corruption and the results will appear
later so it was during your tenure when
kurdistan voted to become independent
from iraq in 2017 you called the
referendum results void and imposed a
flat ban or the region back then and so
the declaration kind of just fizzled out
if the independence talk makes a
comeback in Erbil will Iraq commit to
military action to bring the Kurds back
into line well is I think we are
partners in this country and we when you
take decision as partners you have to
consult the other party it's not right
that you take unilateral action we're
living in the same country well as
living in the same region we have many
ties my might my answer to our Turkish
partners in this country is that we
should work together if you want to
achieve positions and get power and get
benefits so that you'll work towards
independence it doesn't work because
this will not establish trust between
the Kurdish region and the rest of Iraq
we have to establish trust you have to
decide you are part of this nation part
of this country you have to take that
final decision and then move forward
then we are partners in everything but
Kurdistan's Prime Minister net serve on
Barzani told me that Baghdad neglects
the needs of the curt's and that it
doesn't treat them fairly in the federal
state should the Kurds expect any change
in Baghdad so attitudes towards them now
well I think this is the solution as I
said I think
there is no way other than coming back
to back that for our killed citizens I
think they have been very eager to build
a relationship with our neighborhood
countries but you know our neighbors
they'd only encourage establishing a
Kurdish state because they don't allow
independent or even seen it Samia Tamas
autonomous Kurdish region in their own
country so but in Iraq we allow it the
Kurds are part of our country they have
their autonomous region and we are
working with them within the framework
of whatever state the federal state has
got this zone authority and the regions
they have their own authority we
shouldn't weaken the federal authority
on the account of the region and we
shouldn't weaken the region or that
control the federal state that's how
work it out how we work out and I think
we have been very successful at the end
of 2013 and 2018 we established a
relationship we opened the airport of
the region of Kurdistan we opened the
trade again and I think we have to build
along these lines going back to the
referendum and trying again it will
backfire I can tell you all right thank
you very much for this insight we were
talking to haider al-abadi former prime
minister of iraq discussing the fragile
balance of powers in the country that's
it for this edition of Sophie and Co
I'll see you next time
[Music]